you should probably read all your poems
out loud
dogs are very good to read poetry too
cats not so much
fish are good if you have a goldfish
your first audience
before you send your poetry out into the
world
[Music]
poetry does not need a story that's not
what its function is
poetry makes a lot of people tense that
you speak english this poem is in
english
and yet you have no idea what it means
a lot of poetry begins as a secret and
covert activity so poetry is sort of a
diary
without the law a diary that you want
people to read
poem often has two subjects the starting
subject and then the discovered subject
i was as sure as a boy could be that
this
useless worthless thing i wove out of
boredom would be enough
to make us even the poem wants to leave
the object
and go beyond it into something greater
this is what poets are paid for i mean
to like look at clouds watch chipmunks
someone has to keep an eye on these
things
i like to make a real mess i like to
doodle cross
things out i try to write a good line
and then another good line another good
line but no one's a good line
machine so there's a lot of staring
involved
poetry provides us with a history of the
human heart if you trace it back to the
oldest poems we can find the emotions
are the same
underneath it all we're all after the
same thing when you read something back
that it just has your mark on it no one
else could have written that but you
this voice is just yours and yours alone
i'm billy collins and this is my master
[Music]
class
you